you won the Emmy just just to make you
the only I mean they only gave out one
this year I got one I got it I got it
they drew my name out of the Hat Yai no
no you deservedly won and you tweeted
this picture afterwards if you
celebrating at Arby's and I love this
photo I was I was driving around with my
brother afterward and he said oh let's
go to Arby's make a picture of you with
your with your Emmy in front of Arby's
and we did it as a joke but of course
I'm like it was like 3 a.m. and we had a
bottle of scotch in the car so that was
the pose I did thinking this will be
funny
and I got so many emails Twitter
messages Facebook here you okay manners
everything like they were seriously
worried I was like oh no I did it and I
realize it wasn't that fact it's 3 a.m.
or even my facial expression or the
bottle of scotch it's that I'm in at
Arby's that's what made people go we
should send some yeah I guess yeah I for
hello yeah and all of it is just to be
and the why but it like that's our beast
get send a team send a team down there
right now get it into some art therapy
or something
anyone that's okay but still you know
there's a there's a party after the
Emmys called the Governor's Ball
I still think hanging out at Arby's
might might beat the governor's balls it
was you know the Governor's Ball was
gorgeous but it was so I had so much
anxiety because there are a lot of the
shows I like Game of Thrones I love I
love to Game of Thrones and I also I
also love orphan black and I was so
afraid because I would like I saw like
Peter Dinklage and Tatiana maslany or
walk around I'm like what if they get
drunk and I start talking and they blab
spoilers for the next so I was trying to
avoid I didn't want them so that I was
more secure at Arby's because no one was
gonna walk up and say you know Hodor
comes back at now shut up so
no I was so trying to avoid I literally
saw Peter Dinklage backstage and I tried
I ran away from because I didn't want
him right he thinks everyone hates him
just huge fans your spoilers yeah
especially because they've gone off of
the books now so God knows what's coming
right I don't want him blabbing it your
Emmy acceptance speech I like that you
think he's just blurting out spoilers
left and right I get the grocery store
here's your here's your Bernie turns
into a dragon
you wouldn't do that yeah I have a
secret twin thanks for the fries
[Laughter]
you